Aaron Sampson here to talk about burst
fire the tactical shooter made by the
devs who did Hawking if you see the
footage of this game and you feel like
it's a little bit like Rainbow six siege
that's because it was heavily inspired
by Rainbow six eh it's a 5v5 Onelife
tactical shooter the devs are not shy
about saying they watched a trailer for
siege and felt very strongly that this
was a mode like deathmatch that anybody
could do and then they felt they had
their own take on it it has a lot of the
same phases as siege you have your
scouting and fortifying phase with
strong and weak barricades the strong
barricades even have like similar spike
pattern on the other side of the wall
when you're attacking there are things
that I really like about it - it's
continuing the trend of tactical
shooters that have longer times to kill
like you know in my mind over the years
games like Battlefield which I would
talk about their time to kill has been
going more and more towards Call of Duty
where you spawn practically before your
old body hit the ground that's where
everything's been headed so it's nice
seeing these tactical shooters going
back in the other direction where you
actually get into gunfights that last a
while you use tactical destruction in
this game in much the same way as siege
to breach walls or if you're trapped in
a room to escape through walls although
it doesn't have the same level of micro
destruction that siege has there are
very specific walls that you can get
through now what's different about burst
fire
there's no classes every class can take
any loadout with them you'll see some
similar gadgets like the you know
scouting drones but they also have
different ones they have a hover drone
they have a bunch of different types of
grenades and they have a pretty wide
range of weapons they have some also new
things that they've done for example on
the scouting phase when you walk into
the room you can tag the fortifying
enemies but then you can also set a
marker for yourself which is really
useful because you're gonna put it on
the the door that they did not fortify
and then when you spawn in as the
attacking team you can actually just go
right to your marker and breach that
wall and gives you kind of a greater
chance of success the lean was very
generous in this game so it really
encourages you to move slow
lene as a matter of fact they said they
have a counter-strike player on staff
who when they started was doing his run
and gun style and they just kept
changing the mechanics and upping the
pain on this guy until he couldn't run a
gun anymore essentially until he stopped
so the devs were saying that they're
doing as much as they can to prevent
that from happening in this title the
map
convention that we played was also
pretty varied there was about four
different hacking locations some of them
had long sight lines in some of them
were close quarters so even though we
played the same map a bunch of different
times it felt like a fairly different
experience each time we played it and
then they also have some nice little
touches such as if you wound somebody
below I think they said it was about 20%
health that person leaves a blood trail
so you can actually you know if you're
strong if it's like 5v2 or something or
for v2 the people who you've wounded you
can chase them down through the level
actually looking at the blood trail but
I'm sure that at some point people will
learn intellectualize also like a
trapping mechanic so that was kind of
that was kind of cool and interesting
this will probably be a good place to
cut your teeth on tactical multiplayer
shooters because the mode is based on
Rainbow six siege is mode and the siege
beta isn't that until you know after
this title launches you know the dev
also expressed a desire that this game
will grow over time it's gonna be just a
one-time purchase and they feel that
they want to evolve this mode into their
own unique mode so basically what
they're saying is I guess by the time
siege comes out they'll have added a lot
more tools and weapons and sort of
taking this in a different direction so
it won't feel too similar to Rainbow six
siege but whether that happens we'll
still have to see burst fire hits steam
early access on August 6 if you want to
check it out
you're all clear gentlemen now nothing
stands between you and that Intel
you